[Music]
hi I'm Taylor and this is the life of
property investment
hi welcome to this lovely house here in
the northwest and where myself and my
wife's are going to spend the next 24
hours turning it from the end of a
refurbishment program into an up and
running ready to go
[Music]
[Music]
no savings
what yeah Thank You major
you see what is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well for a thing which is important in
license HMOs they're they're mandatory
rather than everything to protect our
protecting our investment particular
find investment and ultimately our
content properly and safe okay so
situation we've got is the way that the
stuff works with LMPD and curry's now is
that we spend a pay by card we can't now
a bank transfer and so we said all out
of Saturday for being a weekend the bank
transfers in hit till this morning we
want delivery today so a couple of
options one is that we can see that go
through they can release product where
they have available in local stores the
other thing is we've got to do a quick
search find a local independent retailer
and see what we can find here for our
fish freezers pretty confident we can
make something happen
just take a little bit of know in the
labels Myrna
[Music]
this is a day in the life of a property
investor getting bossed around by the
Nicias make life a lot easier that was a
very few shot like night ghost weather
making the
make you like not sorry yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
job thanks we had word now that the
funds I got through to to Dixon's and PC
world who are using and we've been a
source the one it goes locally so at the
moment our contact there is just making
sure the paper that I that there's
probably him now
it is Oh
morning Paul speaking hey J hey going I
know I know I we new best friends
brilliant it'll probably be around about
other twelve thirty one o'clock that
area okay your email confirmation of the
order yes I'll have my phone with me so
there's some other good with it being on
a phone and the extras over just going
to refund back to us by bank transfer
okay that's fine it always I'm going to
come back to me than it is for me to get
here in it's just a pin it just been
actually fantastic thank you put out the
stops for us that really gets that gel
your stuff thanks so much make you take
it have a great day
there you go so all confirms white goods
are good for one o'clock we're going to
pick them up get them in here and we'll
have our two fridge freezers and our
washing machine in place Department any
HMOs making sure you got the notice
board Satan fix all these factory
notices all things like gas inspection
your magic
action the Democrats and we've got
contact information for the agent so you
know I've always wanted two of these you
can see straight from Ikea
the other thing was really important to
have poster acts both for each of the
rooms which imagine getting numbered up
on the front side but also for yourself
as well if every post will come across
checking the listicle in confusion so
we've got wine glasses tumblers mugs on
an ironing board or the microwave
details of them does everything but
anything's this has no clothes errors
anything like that that's one thing's
got to add onto our list it's got pretty
much everything else got potato peel
isn't this much like the fusions are
great because they got this this is this
great kit this you can get covers most
of the stuff and actually come in the
store and put it in in the drawers who
as well if you want to unpack everything
to take away all the waste so they're
their price points again with l npg
discount it's actually fantastic
[Music]
already lucky FC the fill box is great
because it also doubles up as a handy
step when you don't have a ladder with
you talk with you now I'm going to just
hang this lampshade up
[Music]
[Music]
so goal is to have the HMO live by the
end of the week we've got some expected
demand and if it comes to fruition
people becoming yet coming the suitcase
in a few days
[Music]
[Applause]